quand on vit de l'agriculture on ne
compte pas ses heures en particulier
quand on s'occupe d'animaux pour faire
en sorte que le métier soit moins
accaparant et palier du même coup la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre en agriculture
de nouveaux modèles commencent à émerger
voici l'exemple d'un producteur laitier
au lac saint jean qui est en quête d'un
meilleur équilibre entre travail et
loisirs
[Musique]
guillon paradis à l'âme d'un aventurier
ce grand amateur de plein air et de
voyages a déjà mené une vie de nomade
puis il a effectué un retour à l'inter
son métier le passionne mais il est
accaparant aujourd'hui à l'aube de la
quarantaine il aspire à davantage de
liberté je veux pas qu'elle devrait
prendre toute ma place sur la situation
sur ma vie et je veux mourir ont gardé
la porte ouverte pour d'autres choses
guillaume et producteurs laitiers en
2016 quand l'heure de la retraite a
sonné pour ses parents il n'a pas hésité
à acheter l'entreprise familiale la
ferme
marlyse à normandin au lac saint jean
j'ai tout à costa rica cela plus à
changement quand même d'intervenir au
monde sur une ferme sur une terre donc
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose que je
voulais pas laisser passer
[Musique]
il est propriétaire d'un troupeau de 115
bêtes dont 60 vaches en lactation
il possède des terres des bâtiments et
de l'équipement agricole il a agrandi
les tables et là plusieurs projets en
tête
son père lui donne encore un bon coup de
main et il a un employé mais il
travaille tout de même 80 heures par
semaine ce qui lui laisse bien peu de
temps libre j'ai quatre heures par jour
moi je ne peux pas aller plus loin qu'à
deux ans par où l'eau parce qu'au bout
de deux ans au genre vient de fermer la
jetée là
[Musique]
comment je fais des centaines de
milliers de dollars par année la danse à
l'air qu'est ce que tu veux que je
savais c'est ça dans le fond il a tenté
de recruter des employés
or le taux de roulement est élevé et
souvent les bons employés veulent gérer
leur propre entreprise
pour guillaume le constat s'est vite
imposé les gens veulent ils veulent un
pouvoir de décision
les gens veulent un sentiment
d'appartenance et les gens évaluent est
rémunéré à la hauteur de ce qu'ils
rapportent sur l'entreprise fait que
c'est tout ce que j'ai mis ensemble
c'est comme ça que je crée mon modèle
enfant
voici son modèle son rêve
l'entreprise agricole bâti par ses
parents votent aujourd'hui environ 3
millions de dollars c'est la ferme
laitière type et qu'au québec guillaume
veut rester l'unique propriétaire de la
terre et conserver la valeur actuelle
des bâtiments et des équipements de la
ferme mais il cherche un alter ego un
partenaire pour cultiver les terres et
exploiter la ferme laitière avec lui ils
se partageront les revenus de la ferme
et les dépenses futures l'avantagent
pour son éventuel associés sait qu'il
n'aura pas à verser de mise de fonds de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
dollars pour devenir copropriétaires à
pérenniser temps modernes
l'agronome denis larouche est guillaume
à peaufiner les détails du projet comme
son principe c'est dire la frontière
c'est dur à pays c'est dur a achevé sa
je veux le garder pour moi puis tout le
reste
si quelqu'un veut s'associer avec moins
on va faire une photo ou un moment donné
de ce que je vaux puis la suite on va se
partager soit 55 ans donc cette personne
mais à partir de jour loeb on arrête une
tare dans le matin belle attaque on
achète à la portion o2 quelques autos
qu'on achète plus appartient aux deux le
topo à garazi appartient aux deux les
copropriétaires rembourseront la dette
actuelle ensemble la diminution de la
dette fera grimper la valeur de la ferme
ils en bénéficieront tous les deux et
ils décideront conjointement du
développement de l'entreprise et des
envies
6 - futur
guillaume a prévu une période d'essai
d'un an à salaire avant de s'engager
pour s'assurer que son éventuel associés
et lui partagent la même vision
lafon cherche le frère que j'ai peau et
parce que bon chemin frère et associé
avec ont souvent ce portage à des fins
de semaine entreprises qui sont deux
frères font en général
le modèle de guillaume offre aussi de la
souplesse les futurs partenaires
partageront les revenus au prorata du
temps travaillé pendant l'année chaque
associé pourra s'offrir du temps libre
on peut faire un métier
on peut faire un voyage s'occuper de sa
famille il doctement données sont
ensemble puis un autre moment donné
c'est guillaume qui puissent et 7 ans
sont associés qui s'occupe de la
business à ce moment là donc ça prend
quelqu'un qui est de la responsabilité
que cas de la graine d'un drop renard
guillaume devra aussi être à l'écouté
s'adapter et forcément faire des
compromis
c'est pas son fils c'est pour sa fille
donc un moment donné il va falloir
concept des choses si t'as pas cette
concession la nature ici rapport à
atteindre son objectif
parce que dans le fond est un vendeur
[Musique]
trouver le partenaire idéal n'est pas
simple guillaume fait donc appel aux
services de l'artère cette organisation
jumelles des aspirants agriculteurs à
des propriétaires de fermes ses dires
elle appelle à la blague c'est encore
pire qu'un mariage s'il ya tout les
jours le froid qu'il essayait de
travailler ensemble au flou qui
développent ensemble
la perle rare pourra bâtir sur des bases
solides
la ferme laitière de guillaume et
rentable mais il faut aussi assurer
l'avenir de la ferme à long terme dit au
matin qui a pas de râler puis attend que
c'est moins la société g de lard aller à
la salle la difficulté de du transfert
va voir ça pour venir à zéro parce que
le fondeur n'a pas été transféré donc
comment on fait pour pérenniser ça on
peut penser peut-être à des produits qui
vont grandir comme des produits
d'assurance qui pourrait grandir au même
titre que la valeur du fonds de terre ce
concept de ferme à partager sort des
sentiers battus et il y a des sceptiques
dans le milieu agricole
j'ai déjà entendu là-bas n'était pas un
des points mais il est tout le temps là
le font parce que c'est mon dieu c'est
kaz main c'est un peu tabou l'os
moi ce que vous confirmez que guillaume
c'est un bon agriculteur c'est un vrai
agriculteurs
il
et avec la pénurie de main d'oeuvre et
le manque criant de relève en
agriculture des partenariats comme celui
que propose guillaume ne viendront sans
doute incontournable
tout change moyen du modèle agricole
change aussi ça prend un peu de liberté
il faut trouver un équilibre entre le
travail et le loisir le projet de
guillaume le demandent clairement que
cet équilibre est atteignable pic est
elle nécessaire
[Musique]
à sa façon en faisant fi des tabous
guillon paradis ouvre la voie à une
nouvelle génération d'agriculteurs
je pars une semaine tu arrêter et faire
la descente de rivière en canot mais je
porte et je propose ma sauce et l'enfant
je veux juste être capable de dire si je
veux partir je suis capable
c'est toute la différence est là
m